that did happen once this guy's never
met a hash he didn't like reefer madness
is all right yeah he's accidentally have
fun of me it's fine
reefer madness yeah yeah like that who
hasn't seen that one a thousand times
before if you're gonna take a good one
you wanna you know you do about 90
minutes of glam before it okay the
makeup hair gots to glam yeah and then
gonna write I'm naughty
Wow there are so many I like when you go
through them all and then get back to
just nothing but you've seen them all
right what's out there so you can feel
confident just being yourself
yeah no filters no filter that was slow
the best way to get new followers on
social media is to get Dwayne Johnson or
Kevin Hart to tell their followers to
follow yeah or just have like one
account of yours that's already got me
on its erotic Rihanna I was gonna say
just buy a bunch of bots like 400 hours
really yeah big BOTS by this guy buys
more bossing widths and people in the
first Star Wars film give me that
and I'm being razzed here full
transparency little transparency just
gets out throw them under the bus
yeah blame your ex for everything then
just post a bunch of nude pictures of
yourself most of yourself but not them
generally lately we've been doing a lot
of laughing while crying guy like that
was like again point is again a lot of
that yeah it's about killing yourself
while laughing but don't kill yourself
lemon it would be writes itself again
you wouldn't do the crown too
you can throw the crown lemon at the
crown feel yeah and then like one of the
the one of like Becky with the good hair
oh yeah yeah women the women like very
good Sarah number like ammo do like
paper being ripped like like divorce
papers being ripped up cuz they only it
worked out as okay now I don't think
that exists okay look I'm not that
which dude in there looks like I'm her
baby hey the weird red devil masks
that's cruel
she doesn't look like that I guess more
scared she's like a bunch of trolling
right well interspersed with dollars
that like flying colors
well musical notes dollars and troll
yeah uh no hot fires in 100 yeah I say
so I mean if I was gonna go out on a
limb and say do they have one where the
chart shows up I know they have a little
zig zagging oh yeah yeah and probably a
lot of like hearts and stuff it's real
fuel
you've been wired and we've been us
you've been wired it's hell honey yes
and why that's something they say